- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical age.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
- Dobzhansky said that
nothing in biology makes sense
except in the light of evolution.
However, John Coffin said,
"Although no biological
explanation makes sense
"except in the light of evolution,
"it does not follow that all
evolutionary explanations
"make sense."
So take everything you heard today,
including what I said,
with a grain of salt.
Another important point
when it comes to humans,
as Dobzhansky himself said,
"Human evolution cannot be understood
"as a purely biological process,
"nor can it be adequately described
"as a history of culture.
"It is the interaction
of biology and culture."
What we would now call
gene culture co-evolution.
"There exists a feedback
between biological
"and cultural processes."
At the end of the day, we're
still talking about humans
as part of biology.
Nikko Tinbergen suggested
that any biological entity
should ask how does it function,
how did it evolve, how
did the entity develop,
how does it develop during a lifetime,
and what are the proximate causes
that regulate its behavior?
So we can ask the same
questions about human
and nonhuman awareness of
death and understanding
of personal mortality.
Because of lack of time,
I'm not going to give you
my opinions on it.
Just think about these questions
and whether they have been answered today.
The CARTA questions
are, are humans unusual
in aspects of these features?
I think we are.
The question is a lot
more we need to learn.
When did these unusual aspects
appear in human evolution?
Again, we left a lot of
questions unanswered.
And finally, what is the impact
on the current human condition?
At CARTA, we tend to focus
on the origins of humans
and where we came from and
tend to not spend a lot of time
about how it impacts us directly.
Obviously, we're very interested in that.
I'd like to point out that
Ingrid Benirschke-Perkins
has been in contact with
several organizations relevant
to death awareness and mortality.
Here's a list of academic
and research organizations
as well as general and public
outreach organizations.
These are all very active groups
and some of them are actually
represented here today
who have spread the word
about this symposium.
I encourage you to get involved in this
because I think we all need
to not only face this problem
but also talk about it freely,
both from the evolutionary
perspective as well as
the practical perspective.
With that, I'm going to
start up the question
and answer session, and
Nick is going to lead
the first session.
I need to get questions
for the second session,
if there are any.
I'm going to quickly go through them.
Nick's up next, I think.
- How do children of atheists get to know,
what do they learn about death?
It's obviously a rather
difficult issue to research
in the United States because
there aren't enough of them.
But around the world, there
are, of course, parents
who do not believe in the afterlife
or any religious interpretation.
Has any study been done
of those sorts of families
and whether they, even
possibly, actually invent
the afterlife for themselves.
Paul?
- I'm afraid the short answer
to that particularly interesting question
is that we don't know.
The research has not been conducted.
Although it would be
fair to say, of course,
that any child growing up
with an atheistic family,
certainly in the United States,
or Western Europe or Scandinavia,
where atheism is more
frequent, may not be exposed
exclusively to atheistic assumptions
about the nature of death.
They will hear other voices
and so a more complex
answer to the question
is how do children sift these
various, competing voices
which they are likely to hear?
One other point, which
is that there are places,
particularly contemporary China,
where the dominant view, at least,
there's no institutionally
or government sanctioned
afterlife beliefs, and so
research there would be
obviously worthwhile conducting.
- Question for either
Dr. Biro or Dr. Marzluff.
Let's give it to Dr. Marzluff.
What do we know about
the reaction of a dog
to the death of its
human caregiver or owner?
Of course, we're all familiar, I'm sure,
with stories about
Greyfriars Bobby and so on.
Dora, you come up and answer it too.
- Sorry, I think I spoke to the lady
who asked this question during the break.
There are some very interesting
anecdotal stories about
dogs essentially mourning
the death of their owners.
I'm currently on sabbatical in Japan
and Japan has one of these
very, very famous stories.
Many of you will probably know.
A dog owner who used to take
his dog to the train station
every day for I can't
remember how many years,
and would leave him there, go off to work,
and then come back in the evening,
and the dog would be there at the station,
waiting for him every single day.
When the owner passed away
without the dog's knowledge,
I guess, in the sense
that the dog wasn't there
when the owner died,
the dog continued to turn
up at the train station
daily for I think 19 years
or something like that.
There is now a statue to this
dog at that train station
in Tokyo.
I think anecdotally at least, we've got
some extremely striking cases of dogs
with very, very strong bonds
to their human owners keeping
those strong bonds going
even beyond death.
- Jack, another one for you.
The questioner says in
London, she saw crows
attacking and killing another crow.
Can you comment on that, and
how they can at the same time
be fascinated by the death of an animal,
but also bring it about?
- There have been lots of
documentations of crows
killing other crows and
ravens killing ravens.
There might be several
motivations for that.
Some of them just involve
with territorial excursion,
going in the wrong territory
and being attacked.
Once a victim is basically helpless,
others pile in on that
and kill that animal.
It's pretty routine.
I had seen it myself when
a bird was hit by a car
and it was wounded and fluttering around.
Other crows killed that individual.
These sorts of things happen.
It might be somewhat misdirected
behavior in that case.
But there is a very
interesting study from Austria
where ravens were socially
punishing each other
for social transgressions.
They would break the other
raven's wing in that respect.
So they didn't kill it, but
they functionally killed it,
rendering it unable to fly.
That one was harder to explain
as kind of a misdirected bit of behavior.
- Another question for Paul.
Dora Biro discussed whether
or not it's a good idea
to let animals in zoos
be exposed to the death
of their cellmates, zoomates.
Does Dr. Harris think
it would be a good idea
for humans to be exposed to the death,
directly exposed to the
death of children or family
in a way which doesn't
happen generally now?
- Yes, I'm very reluctant to
draw prescriptive conclusions
from the modest research base we have.
I guess what we do know
is that around the world,
children very dramatically
in the extended exposure
to death, so for example,
it would be nice to hear
from Rita, if I can identify her,
who will tell you about the
role that children are ascribed
both prior to death and
immediately thereafter
in Madagascar.
- Yeah, so if you followed
the description I gave
of the funerals, I did
mention the children.
But you should imagine at the gathering,
especially when the meals are happening,
as people arrive at the village,
newcomers tend to go into the house
and they will see the deceased
person for the first time.
There are these eruptions
of wailing and crying.
The kids who are basically
there to hang out
and eat the food and play,
you kind of have these
movements of gathering
and they try to evade.
I guess attracted and
scared by what's going on,
so you would only see them
hanging from the windows
and trying to peer into the house
to witness both the kind
of display of emotion
and through that, also, to get
a close view of the deceased,
which the corpse is laid in the house,
and they're in this kitchenette.
It's a very powerful experience,
which is paired up with a very
hands-on experience of animal death,
so children are playing with animals,
literally playing with animals
and kind of inspecting them
quite inquisitively by
pulling bits to say,
"Oh, it's not moving anymore.
"It's dead."
There is this experience of
animal death and human death
which is much more available than it is
in our societies.
And then there are these
very dramatic moments
for some children, so if
a mother or a father dies,
I'm not sure about siblings,
but certainly we've seen it
with parents, children are
kind of, just before the coffin
gets closed to be taken
away to the cemetery,
the children are taken
and kind of forced to
face the face of the deceased.
They're kind of put on top of the coffin
and they're told, look,
this is your mother,
she's dead, never again utter her name.
There is a taboo.
You can refer to the mother
but you shouldn't use the name
with which she was known.
There's this very
dramatic separation moment
of face-to-face with
the body of the parent.
So anyway, yeah, it's a
very available experience,
which I think is integrated
in both, Paul hinted
in his talk, suggested
in his talk that children
pick up the notion that there is something
that survives after death
after they have consolidated
the biological understanding of death,
and that came through
in Madagascar as well,
in the research we've done together.
It seems that, though
logically it doesn't have to be
that way, it seems that
before children can understand
the ancestors, these people
who have arrived at the place
where they are, as I described them,
they kind have to put together
the biological understanding
of this dead body and what that means.
- Question about how facial
expressions in mammals
fit into your revised model of fear.
I think what this could be about,
you've talked about these
subconscious limbic reactions
which can produce flight
and escape and so on.
But they can also produce
frightened, fearful faces.
That's obviously not to
do with escaping anything.
What do you see as the
role of facial expressions
associated with fear, yes, you, Joe,
and why is it we find
these so easy to read
across species, and could other species
read them across species too?
- I think this is a good
example of the conflation
that we have between
innate behavior patterns
and subjective experiences.
So the expression on a
face is not controlled
by the same system in
the brain that gives rise
to the subjective experience.
I think those have to be kept separate.
What was the followup?
- [Nicholas] Whether there's
cross species recognition.
- Right, first of all you asked
about the universality of it.
But that's been questioned.
If you show people these pictures
and give them multiple choice
answers to select from,
they're more accurate than if they have to
spontaneously generate,
it's fear, anger, whatever.
That doesn't mean that there
aren't certain recognizable
expressions around the world,
because obviously there are
to some extent.
Again, these are innate
patterns that are different
from the experiences that people have.
So these patterns, some of
them can be obviously conserved
across other primates and people,
even dogs in certain mouth movements.
There's nothing magical about that.
Those are just behaviors
that have been wired in
because of their signal
value and their ability
to direct behaviors of other animals.
So I think it's just
important that we separate
the experiences, subjective experiences,
that we interpret to go with these faces,
because sometimes they do
and sometimes they don't.
Expressions are not 100%
reliable way of judging
exactly what's on someone's mind.
- What do you think function
of expressing fear is?
Obviously you don't really want your enemy
to know how you're feeling, do you?
- Well, I would call it
expressing responses to threats
rather than fear itself.
I think that's one of
those just so stories.
We don't know why exactly we do this.
It may be signaling for conspecifics.
If you're expressing
some response to danger,
other like kinds can use that
as a signal to stay away and
perhaps extend their life.
- Most of the matter in
the universe we cannot see
or characterize, and
we understand so little
of the origins of consciousness.
Is it not, therefore,
foolish to dismiss concepts
we currently consider
magical or religious--
Sorry, in practicum, we conclude--
I think the message is,
should you be considering
some alternative kind of explanations
for our reality denial and
religious beliefs and so on,
because actually, they may not
just be defense mechanisms,
they may get closer to the
truth of the world we live in.
Where's Ajit?
There you are.
- I don't have a specific
answer except to say
that I just presented
one possible explanation
for a lot of phenomena,
but you can see that today,
we've raised a lot more questions
than answers, so I don't think
it just bespeaks the notion
that this whole area
needs a lot more research.
I'd just keep my mind open about it.
- I think we've run the
gamut with these questions.
Should we go to yours?
- OK.
All right, so many of the
questions are very personal
and lengthy and hard to deal
with in a general audience,
so those who had the
very personal questions
should probably approach
the specific speaker
if they have a question.
A question to Sheldon.
Comment on the field of neuroethology,
study of the brain during
religious experience.
And perhaps comment on
the near-death experience.
- I'm not equipped on the
neuroethology part of the question
to weigh in.
There is a body of literature
that I'm vaguely aware of
that shows that a particular
part of one's brain
lights up in the context of
any religious experience,
broadly defined.
Interesting and perhaps important,
but I'm literally not
sufficiently familiar
or have the skills to judge.
Near death experiences are
also complex and difficult.
We are, I am, in conjunction
with a graduate student
at the University of Padua in Italy,
Simone Bianco, we're
studying people that have had
near-death experiences
and we're thinking about
them as natural phenomena,
which just means we're
agnostic with regard
to what's actually happening.
Our interest is just the
psychological consequences
of having had those experiences.
We're trying to assemble a
large enough group of people
around the world to have
had near death experiences,
and we're comparing them
with a matched control group
of folks who have not to see
what happens in our experiments
when they're subliminally
primed to be reminded
of their mortality.
If you ask folks that have
had near death experiences
to comment on what has
happened to them thereafter,
they fairly consistently
say that these are
transformative experiences
and that for the most part,
they're no longer afraid of dying.
I'll get back to you if we come back again
in a year or two, I'll let you know.
Or please do write me
if anybody's interested,
and I'll let you know the
outcome of that research.
- One more question.
- Sure.
- Another question to Sheldon.
If increased awareness
of inevitability of death
and our mortality exacerbate
individual and societal
maladaptive behaviors,
how do we move toward
an acceptance of death?
- (laughs) To be silly
at the end of a long day,
if I could answer that question,
I would be chugging rum out of a coconut
with my Nobel Prize on
the beach someplace.
What I would say, these
are great questions,
what I would say, I do
believe this is important.
We need to distinguish between
the relatively fleeting reminders of death
that we use in our studies.
So somebody standing in
front of a funeral parlor,
somebody where we blast the
word death subliminally,
they're not even aware
that that has happened.
That's very different than a
sustained and very conscious
contemplation of one's mortality
that a lot of religious and
philosophical traditions
are advising.
The Tibetan Book of the Dead,
or the medieval monks
that work with a skull
on their desks, or anybody
who's had enough free time
and read Heidegger's Being and Time.
It's taken me a lifetime.
That's surely more than fleeting.
I suspect, and I think this gets back to
something that Nick said
at the end of his talk,
and some of the other folks have also,
and that's culture matters.
As a grotesque
overgeneralization, we in the West
live in a culture where
we go to great lengths
to kind of bury death anxiety.
It's not death anxiety per se
we would argue that produces
pernicious outcomes.
It's when we psychologically
speaking, try and banish it
and bury it underneath
the psychological bushes
that it comes back to
bear malignant fruit.
Ajit had a list of
organizations up on the screen,
and many of them, such as the Death Cafe,
I think are well intentioned efforts
to provide very public
spaces so that people,
generally in a secular society,
can start to have open
and candid conversations.
I think that would be a good start.
- Related to that,
to Colin Renfrew, if Western
society were to continue
in a most secular path,
rejecting the concept
of an afterlife and the
immortality of the soul,
could we expect a decline in
death and mourning rituals?
- I think not necessarily so.
Ritual is something
which doesn't necessarily
depend, I suppose it always
depends to some extent,
on a worldview.
But it doesn't depend on a
worldview which involves belief
in a deity or a divinity
or in an afterlife.
I think it's the case,
as indeed we've seen,
we've talked of these early burials
in the upper Paleolithic period,
which were clearly seriously undertaken
and very carefully undertaken.
At that time, of course,
it's very difficult
to talk about the development of religion
in prehistoric times, when
we don't have written texts,
and in those very early times,
we don't have any way of denying
that there may have
been religious beliefs.
But we certainly don't
have any iconography
that would promote a notion that there was
a specific divinity.
It would be too long an
aside to go on to talk about
what I think are probably
the erroneous ideas
of a great earth mother in
upper Paleolithic times.
But clearly, as we've
heard so well documented,
death does engender regret
in those living and mourning
in those that remain.
There, we've had very
interesting narratives
about how the ceremonies of mourning
are not always focused
on regret of the passing
of the deceased person,
but have very active life
in the remaining community.
I think it's appropriate, and
I think for an agnostic person
it is appropriate to note that
passing of a deceased person,
a friend or someone who is much admired.
So I think the commemoration of the dead
does not need to be based on any
sincere or sophisticated
religious belief systems.
I don't know if that answers--
Brief answer.
- Question for Nick.
Could we not equally consider suicide
as a positive selection mechanism
against diseases of evolution
and disadvantageous states of mind?
In other words, could have
suicide have been selected for
rather than a failure to select against?
- I think you could make a case
that some suicides, if
they were undertaken
with that kind of motive,
could have been selected
for, to take yourself
out of society when you're sick
or a burden on others.
Would actually end up increasing,
it can be a eugenic mechanism of a sort.
There's no evidence that
animals do anything like that,
which suggests that we're
not likely to find it
in humans unless it's
a highly rationalized,
intellectual response.
We do know plenty of
examples, interesting enough,
of altruistic suicide rather like that.
The wonderful example I wish I'd had time
to show the pictures of it to you,
was a village in Derbyshire, in England,
which in 1666, when the
great plague struck,
it arrived in this
village through some fleas
on a bed of cloth which
had been delivered there.
The villagers realized
immediately the danger
they were in.
Their response wasn't to leave,
it was to quarantine the village.
They basically made the
decision, no one will leave,
no one will come on, and food and things
were passed across
through a kind of barrier
which didn't allow any
spread of the disease.
In that village of the 600
people originally there,
400 died.
By doing that, they very likely saved
an awful lot of lives of others outside.
Of course, unrelated,
this is a very high level of selection.
If something like that
was seen to be beneficial
to human genome.
I think yes, the answer
is there are possibilities
that removing ourself could
have positive effects.
I don't think you could
make any case like that
for by far the majority of suicides,
which, as I said, seem to
be largely self-interested,
though I maybe think that's a
hard word to use about them.
They are self-euthanasia.
People are trying to
mend their own inner life
there, in a word.
- It's an appropriate followup.
Could not egoistic suicide be selected for
since it would remove from the gene pool
young people suffering from mental illness
such as depression prior to reproduction?
Increased suicide in
young depressed people
who have a more realistic grasp of studies
showed that non-depressed people
have a more optimistic view
of reality, whereas depressed people
actually have better grasp of reality.
In other words, so-called
depressive realism.
I almost could have written
that question myself.
I didn't.
- Yes, firstly on this
issue of mental illness,
it's hugely exaggerated
the extent to which
suicide is related to mental illness.
It's commonly said in the
West that 90% of suicides
have got major depressive illness.
This is based on so-called
psychological autopsies,
when you ask after someone's died,
you ask their friends and family and so on
what signs of it did you see?
It's of course, the evidence
you get back from that
can be hugely biased.
Once somebody's killed themselves,
in retrospect, of course you
can find all sorts of reasons
why you might have thought
it was going to happen.
My more important point
is that the statistics
of 90% are only for Europe and America.
Across the rest of the world,
India, China, whatever,
you find the rates of
illness, of mental illness
associated with suicide way, way down.
By far, the majority, there's a big review
in science recently, have no identifiable
psychiatric mental illness.
The people in Palawan, I
mentioned Charles McDonald's study
of this area of villages that
have very high suicide rates.
They've recently done a further study
in which they did psychological
autopsies on them.
They found that there was
almost not noticeable evidence
of mental illness.
In one or two, agoraphobia
was apparently present
in some of them, but no major issue
which would have been wise
to remove from the population
by letting these people kill themselves.
I think that's the wrong
way to think about it.
Of course, if you think in eugenic terms,
we're going to ask whether
it would have been better
for the species if these
people hadn't lived,
but I think in the particular cases,
there are cases where people
who are seriously malformed
or ill can volunteer not
to reproduce, for example,
which is a kind of suicide.
That's not always a free
decision which they make,
but certainly in some
cases, there are people
who won't reproduce because they know
that they'd be passing on
faulty genes to their children
and that's a bit like
what you're talking about.
That is a way in which,
not exactly suicide,
but denial of your contribution
to the next generation
could actually benefit the human genome.
- Just putting on my medical hat,
I would suggest, we may
not exactly agree on this,
I would suggest that in all societies,
there's a baseline rate of suicide
that's associated with
major depressive disorder,
which is greatly upticked
when there are activities
of various kinds going on.
We're coming close to the end,
so the final question somebody asked
which is a good one, is
to each of the speakers.
What is the next big question
that the upcoming generation
of researchers should seek to
answer in our study of death?
We just have enough
time for each one of you
to come and give one.
- I've just been speaking,
so someone else first.
- Somebody come forward.
If you could have wave a magic
wand and have as much money
as you want, which experiment would do?
- I need a glass of wine before I come up
with an experiment, but I do think
what these series of talks
have illustrated for me is a sort of,
not a schism, that's too strong a word,
but some of us have talked quite a lot
about the awareness of
one's own personal mortality
and the terror or whatever that evokes.
Others of us, on the other
hand, have thought about
death with respect to loved ones,
those that we lose, and how
we cope with their status
within the broader social fabric.
So it does seem to me that we
researchers, investigators,
might have a longer
conversation about the extent
to which those two lines of investigation
should be brought together, or whether one
is much more important than the other.
In the question of the day, or
the afternoon, I should say,
we did seem to be talking to some extent
about distinct themes.
- Anyone else with a
paradigm for the future?
- I'll offer a quick note.
I think animals are
much more aware of death
than some people think.
Getting at that better, to
understand the connection,
I think the gradient
between how humans view it
and how animals view
it, there's a lot more
that can be done there.
- I'd just like to say how
much more we have to learn
about beliefs in life and in death,
specifically in early
times, in prehistoric times,
and how rich the data is,
and how important it is
that the archeological
data is treated properly,
that is to say, it's excavated
in a way which reveals
its context, so that
we learn something more
about the beliefs of past world systems
and how easily this is destroyed
by either unscrupulous
or careless developments,
but in particular, by
collectors who pay good money
to have artworks from the past
which are ripped from
their archeological context
and all information is thereby lost.
The record of the past
is a diminishing record,
and it's diminished in a very negative way
if people, private
collectors or indeed museums,
pay money to essentially,
in order to have objects
displayed in their museum
without proper context,
they are in fact destroying our hope
of understanding the world's
archeological heritage.
Thank you.
- Now I think I'll hand
over to Pascal Gagneux,
the associate director
has some closing remarks.
- I'd like to thank all of you,
especially the speakers,
for an amazing lineup
of talks, and the audience, those here,
those online, across the
city and across the world.
It's very hard not to be
touched by this topic.
Please remember that, while
alive, you can be kind.
That stops at some point.
Thank you very much and
have a wonderful evening.
(crowd applauding)